[Music]
so now we are back to the monster verse
and I bet we are never going to be more
addicted to any other monster franchise
than this one the incarnations of these
epic guys you are just legendary get it
one intended they have adapted almost
every characteristics of these gigantic
creatures to a near perfect level via
the gravity beams or motorists
bioluminescence or Godzilla's
thermonuclear pulse and this will be the
topic of the day and we will be
discussing the temperature of Godzilla
during his nuclear meltdown and the
atomic pulse of his that incinerated
almost everything in his vicinity
including the false King Ghidorah so
enhanced by a nuclear explosion in his
resting ground Godzilla and advertently
absorbed the energy that boosted his
power on a massive scale causing his
skin to be volcanic in appearance an
atomic pulse to be even more deadlier
however it adversely affected the kaijus
health effectively imposing a death
sentence on him but it became something
else entirely it was predicted that his
meltdown during the latest scenes and
Godzilla king of the monsters was going
to take him down along with everything
else in the area
however he utilized the excess energy
within him to transform into a burning
form and then release it in three or
more consecutive blasts that killed
Ghidorah so how hot was he during his
burning form let us dissect this
question piece by piece and come to a
reasonable answer let us start by
assessing the scene when he walked by
those buildings and they just melted
like butter exposed to a kitchen stove
burning at max power now as we can see
the buildings are made of mostly
concrete and reinforced with steel and
there were also structures close by that
were ayran or more specifically steel so
what is the actual melting temperature
of these substances concrete is a bit
more than a thousand degrees while iron
melts at a bit more than fifteen hundred
degrees Celsius while steel has a lower
melting point at thirteen seventy
degrees these temperatures will
gradually melt them in a slow manner
while being exposed directly in contact
with the source but as we can see these
structures were close to 30 or 50 meters
away from Godzilla in his burning form
so
holiday melt in an instantaneous manner
Godzilla must have been radiating a
temperature of such a high level that
even the insulating effect of the air
around him became nullified ere is
excellent at convection but the amount
of heat that can be transferred is
minimal because of the low mass of the
substance and cannot store a great deal
of heat trapping air and layers is a
very effective way of insulating an
object so how does steel and concrete
melt instantaneously when they are at a
distance from burning Godzilla as we can
see in many movies documentaries and
short videos people can stand near
melted metal and even a volcano crater
but with protective clothing but the
protective gear isn't burned or damaged
even a few feet from it so it stands to
reason that Godzilla was at least twice
or three times as hot as melted steel
given the fact that anything melts
instantaneously near the surface of the
Sun which is around 6,000 degrees
Celsius Godzilla might have come close
to it and it would make sense given the
eternal nuclear state in which he was at
and is the same as a statement which the
Sun is in and both of them have higher
temperatures in the core the place where
the nuclear fusion takes place their
surface temperature is just the tip of
the iceberg when compared to the true
potential so now we know how hot
Godzilla's burning form is at least a
surface which radiates out heat to melt
buildings Ghidorah and Emma Russell but
what about the nuclear pulse as we have
seen Ghidorah was near mu2 his atomic
breath as well as his burning
temperature but most is zero perished
when met with the thermonuclear or
atomic pulse now again it stands to
reason that the atomic pulse was way
hotter than his burning form we can only
explain this with an atomic bomb
explosion so the primary form of energy
from a nuclear explosion is thermal
radiation initially most of this energy
goes into heating the bore materials and
the air in the vicinity of the blasts
temperatures of nuclear explosion
reached those of the interior of the Sun
almost a hundred million degrees Celsius
and produce a brilliant fireball this
fireball loses the initial temperature
but still radiates out as it becomes
bigger so does the temperature decrease
gradually but still in a matter of
seconds
therefore the atomic pulse of Godzilla
ranges from a hundred million degrees
Celsius to a few 10,000 degrees enough
to disintegrate everything in a spark
and with this comes the end of this
video so do like share and subscribe for
more related content about masters
creatures and kaijus